the Joe Rogan experience it does he's
gonna power scooter
wait what goes fast yeah what do you
mean a power is like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
bird scooter but like way faster goes
like 25 miles an hour like a leucine
Bolt Sprint is that a custom made did
you get that how do you you can't buy
that you trying to be trying to kill
white people
hell yeah there's made in America China
no it's not the pieces are it was
probably compiled assembled in China
they got me on the one wheel out there
I'm I [ __ ] I learned it real fast how
many of those maggot hats were made in
China every single one probably every
single work every [ __ ] one I love
that's hilarious
has to be made Chinese [ __ ] you know
fashion wise fashions gonna when he's
gone and all the shit's over within a
decade or so those hats are gonna be so
[ __ ] popular oh yeah earth so much MA
my god it's like dick like dick Nixon
like Richard Nixon that's right that's a
very valuable tricky dick
you can wear a Nixon t-shirt right now
Nixon for president how do percent
nobody would nobody would say don't beat
your ass no why no people will beat your
ass if you have a red hat with other
white letters on it yeah just cause like
there's a girl got mace in the face they
just had a hat that said make Bitcoin
great again someone didn't read it they
just really bother reading it [ __ ] you
with your red hat with white letters
they maister right in the face the video
of it
now I'm ignorant but as this happened
for any other president where this kind
of thing had like did someone were
shirts for another president that was
kind of cool no no no no this is number
one phrases not only that dude how about
what it says make America great again
mm-hmm who's like [ __ ] you we don't want
it to be great
[ __ ] you it's just a representation in
the context they just associated so they
like that's it it's also again like make
it great again like what well was it
great when slavery was legal when was it
great and civil rights wars were going
on one was it great yeah the phrase is
inherently what things are segregated
was it great name the great time what
was it great when we first came here and
we stole it from TSA when it's great
fried now [ __ ] yeah this is good has
ever been it's not gonna get better than
if you pay attention to like real trends
forget about how you feel like forget
about like your own personal experience
if you just look at objective trends in
terms of violence crime all the
statistics that we're all really
terrified about right there's never been
a better time no there's never been a
better time for humanity
but it's always gonna be the United
States it's a pretty goddamn good good
we always wear our best critic you know
[ __ ] Trump just went after Chicago
again you just was making fun of my city
because of the crime rate saying how we
can't get it under control
I was talking about the cops yeah cago
cops yeah saying that that we can't get
crime under control in Chicago well he's
probably making fun of the mayor in some
way oh yeah blaming it on the mayor oh
yeah that's what it is
it's your favorite mayor yeah I love her
well it's just easy to make fun of seems
like a nice lady though we just get shot
Chicago gets shots taken out at all the
time because it's like they're like
[ __ ] Duvall violence it's excellent
all [ __ ] violence well that's what's
even more [ __ ] about it it's a very
specific area that has had extreme
violence for a long time South Side in
the West Side yeah it's dark but then
it's so much meanwhile scary that when
you have a place that like it's where
it's isolated you know where there's
just like so much violence there then
outside of it it's really nice like why
but some of the nice areas we're getting
even like kids would do these things
they do these mob attacks where they go
to like a really nice area like Michigan
Avenue where all the tourists aren't
[ __ ] they maybe would just like rob
someone but they'd be like 15 people on
one you know so they knew that a they
were gonna get away with it and be how
could you stop it's kind of so much K as
like organized chaos and they would run
into a store and steal [ __ ] and just
leave mm-hmm because they figure you're
not gonna get all of us Brian it's like
maybe one person gets caught but rob
from the rich you know I saw a video I
don't know how many times I've done it
right now but groups so it's happened
three times in California twice here is
somewhere else
[Applause]
probably 200 people get on those
scooters and just take over a street and
then just go wherever they can go
oh [ __ ] and the cops are trying to stop
them but there's so many people they
can't stop and the helicopters are on
them
do they organize online yeah yeah
Facebook meetups or something like that
Wow
like what are those things called on one
of those things call when people have
like flash mobs flash mobs I have a
flash mob for scooters yeah I haven't
seen anything dangerous happening but I
mean I'm sure speaking of dangerous what
do you think about what Trump did when
that guy when they killed the head of
Isis and he said he died crying and
whimpering and then he watched the whole
thing on video Mike Jesus he's like a
he's like a deranged comedy writer like
he's like a [ __ ]
like sometimes I think he's like trying
to be funny or clever and it I just
don't it's like an autistic kid he just
doesn't his tick is wrong but that just
does not seem very presidential
no something his tank is off I think he
thinks it's normal or fun or or
interesting or dynamic and people are
like he has no one person next to him
going do we is that what you want us
that's the version that you want to say
because he just I we talked about that
on the plane is like the theory of how
do you tell someone they're wrong when
things have told them that they're right
how do you tell the guy that's like I
won against all odds to become the
president when someone's like you
shouldn't tweet that he's like really
look at all the [ __ ] other stuff that
you know what I mean like it's hard to
convince this guy that he's wrong well
if anybody tells him not to do things he
fires yeah they're gone yeah so it's
just kind of like he's a bunch of yes
men anyway well he's treating the
presidency the same way he treats
running Trump Tower
yeah but is the same thing if I anybody
tells them what to do get the [ __ ] out
here if I had yeah I'm just doing it on
a large scale but do we expect dear
friendly that's what's weird like what
what would you expect different out of a
guy who's 70 what is he 74 no how old's
you mid seventies yeah that's so old to
be running a giant [ __ ] thing like
the presidency allows McDonald's baby
house McDonald's I know loves Kentucky
Fried Chicken what's this
what was it say SME 370 degree did you
see the photo what yesterday oh yeah
there's a lobby were saying this is a
staged photo
yeah it looks it doesn't look god this
Photoshop yeah they liked all the things
are plugged in to the cat five wires
they just kind of laid them around yeah
all the guys are kind of looking in
different directions
[ __ ] let that what kind of IT guy let
that thing be so goddamn sloppy what is
this supposed to be a photo of them
watching that happen because they're
trying to compare it to the one that
happened is the Obama one when they go
bin Laden and everyone's around the
world how weird is it they all watch
that's funny there's a bunch of photos
go down there's a bunch of photoshopped
ones that are coming out now they're
making jokes of it huh
there's Hulk Hogan Sarah Palin's in
there
[Applause]